YouTube I know I said that I would have
put out a video in three days and it's
been five but um an emergency you want
to believe it but a Griffin came down
and he you know kidnapped one of my
babies was like my bad I just
so last week or about five days ago I
told you guys that I was gonna involve
you guys in a project that I was doing
and I figured out what it was now um
this is a project that anybody could do
no matter where yet okay
and in the vaults you very much because
it falls your guys's life stories so
check this out
I thought to myself everybody seems to
like when I go on a vlog and I just kind
of just just just verbally abuse people
and I must and when I found out it was
that not everybody has a voice for
themselves not everybody can go ahead
and speak their mind this is what I want
you guys to do I want you guys to go to
my Facebook fan page okay
and I want you to tell me a story tell
me story about yourself that somebody
just did you turn somebody just did you
wrong and you never really standing into
it because you were either afraid or you
just never knew how to phrase it let me
go ahead and verbally abused these
people here maybe they dumped you maybe
they robbed you maybe they tickled you
and ran away you could never get them
back
so the one with the most thumbs up in
likes is the one that I'm going to
choose and it's the one that I'm gonna
help you out I'm not too sure exactly
how many I'm going to do I might be one
I might do two I might be three but so
just make sure that you make your really
captivating so it's sort of granted
three days you tell me your story for
five days when I'm buckling release it
it might be on a Thursday or Friday
depending on when I want to do it but I
need to hear those stories so I can go
ahead and do this for you so um yeah get
on it um let me go ahead and bring some
self-esteem down for you
the project I was working on while I was
in LA was in the music video with Paul
Kim now that's not know who Paul Kennedy
is this super super talented Korean
brother of mine really down to earth is
a homeboy the music video just got
released today so watch it go ahead and
check it out so it's gonna be leaning at
the end of the video I'm in the music
video with to thinking a lot ghetto it
was super fun it was dope it was fresh
met the dude Timothy funny ass dude made
me laugh crack me up
what can I say but go ahead and check it
out if you if you want to know my role
in the music video it's it's something
else so yeah a lot of you guys have been
asking where do I perform stand up how
can I come and see you in a show the
next biggest one that you guys can come
and see is going to be a collaboration
on September 10th in Berkeley now the
information is gonna be either in this
video we're doing or it's gonna be in
the box below so if you guys want to
come out and see me go ahead and you
know buy tickets for collaboration and
see what stuff
stand-up comedy is my original thing a
lot of you guys have been leaving in the
comments oh you should be a stand-up
comedian [ __ ] that's what I am and
that's but not least big shout out
Funimation for sending me these gifts
I'm a huge one-piece fan so Michelle for
Funimation thank you very much that you
guys actually caught that in one of the
blogs that's pretty insane you don't
know how Gibby I am about this i am i
yes i watch anime I'm Asian I can't help
it
don't judge people I don't judge you for
doing all you say that you do so don't
fall upon the camera say what's up to
you no worry about please don't worry
but it's all the swag you got it you
gotta be actually be classy this is not
a good time for you to be suited me bro
nice okay I'll give a little free stuff
all your fans out there man yo LA
oh where the drugs and the drama beat
Bert I'm here chillin he's so comedy
that's his channel name a rocket
flannels made like I wanna be a rapper
too Tim did you yep I believe that's me
sprinkles off my name won't hear me
rebel big okay okay okay what hey hey
hey hey listen